All right, now that we've seen how we create the pickup
and add score and things like that, what we're going to do
now is we're going to use Unreal Motion Graphics so that we
can create the interface that's going to go on our screen
to show the user their score and the remaining time.
Now, to use this, what we're going to do first
is we are going to create a new Widget Blueprint class
and name it HUD UMG.
We're going to do this by right clicking
in the content browser, going down to Widget Blueprint,
and then selecting our user widget as our widget base.
So let's go ahead and we're going to pop over to the editor.
There we go.
And once we're inside the editor,
we're going to right click on our content browser, user
interface, Widget Blueprint.
From our pick parent class for new Widget Blueprint,
we're going to select the user widget option.
And we are going to call this HUD underscore UMG.
Now, once we have that done, we're
going to double click on it to open it up.
And the first thing that we have to do once we open it up
is add something called a Canvas panel.
Now, a Canvas panel allows us to add and group
other elements to this UMG widget.
Without the Canvas panel, we'd only
be able to put a singular button
or a singular piece of text.
So the Canvas panel allows us to add multiple items
to the same UI.
So let's go ahead and double click on our HUD.
And we're going to go over to the palette
and we're going to search for CAN.
And there's our Canvas panel.
So we're just going to use our left mouse button
to drag and drop this right down onto our hierarchy.
And next, what we're going to do
is we are going to add two pieces of text, one
for our score and one for our time.
Then we're going to position these pieces of text
so that they will be anchored to the left
and the right hand corner at the very top of the screen.
Now, to do this, let's go ahead and add the text first.
So we're going to just take this text
and again, left click, drag on the Canvas panel,
left click, drag on the Canvas panel.
Now, if I click on one of these,
you're going to notice that there's this little flower.
What this little flower icon is displaying
is the location that that object will be pinned to
or as the pivot or the initial location
when the screen is enlarged or reduced in size.
This is super helpful because this means this one UI can
be set up so that whenever it is used
on an ultra wide monitor or a very small phone,
the same UI and all of the buttons and everything
will all still go to the same location
that the user expects without you actually
having to do any extra work or create any additional assets.
So let's go ahead and set these up.
So we're going to select this bottom one.
And the first thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to hold down Control.
I'm going to come over here to my Anchors.
And I'm going to click right over here
on this very right hand one that is flashing.
And that is going to move that text block over there.
And there's a couple of things I need to do.
So first things first, we're going
to set the text size to 64.
Always find that it's easier to position these
in place with the end text, the size that you want it.
If you get it in position and then change the text,
it's going to change how this actually looks
and give you a bad time.
Next thing we're going to do is we're
going to change this to size to content
because we want this size of this
to represent the score or the text.
And we're also going to come up here to our text.
And we're going to call this one time.
So t and e.
And we're going to also come down to our shape outline
and set this.
Whoops, not like that.
We're going to set that to about a 2.
There we go.
And we also need a capital T for our time there.
So there we go.
There's our time.
So now our time is obviously not in the greatest position
because everything needs to be on the inside of this dotted
line.
So what we're going to do is we're
going to go to our position here
and set this to negative 100.
And then we are going to set our position in the y to 100.
And then I'm going to do something kind of cool.
I'm going to take this alignment
and set this to 1 by 1.
Sorry, just 1, I mean.
Not by 1.
There we go.
And what this is going to do is it's basically
going to kind of flip our transform of this
and put it so that it is in the inside over here.
Without us having to go all crazy trying to position
this using the x and the y, I just
find that adjusting the alignment can help.
So again, let's do this same thing over here.
We're going to grab this.
We're going to call this one score.
And then, oops, unselected it.
So we have our time.
We have our score.
So again, 64, size to content, line size 2.
And then what we're going to do
is we're going to go 100 and 100.
There we go.
And that is it.
So we've got our score.
We have our time.
And the coolest part is that they're
going to stay relative to those locations
as our UI changes in size.
So that's exactly the behavior that we want.
And as you can see here, this is what we've got.
We've got our score.
We have got our time.
Now next, what we're going to do
is we are going to set up something called a binding.
And a binding allows us to read from any particular value
that we have inside of one of our blueprints
and then relay that information in our UI.
However, one thing to note here,
bindings can be relatively expensive, especially
as your game progresses and gets
bigger and more complicated.
For this particular project, text binding
in this application isn't really
going to cause that much of a performance issue.
Again, this is something that has another way,
but this is the most simplistic way to do this.
And it could become a performance problem,
especially if you're working on an MMO
or some type of action RPG that
has a very complicated interface that
might be listening to a bunch of values.
This is where you could get into problems with that.
But for our game, we're only going
to be having very, very few things listening to this.
So this is all good.
Now again, what we're going to be doing
is creating a binding.
And that binding is going to link text
from our blueprint to our UI.
And to do that, what we do is we come down to our text
and we click on the menu called Bind,
and then we select the Create Bind option.
So let's go ahead and do that now.
So we're going to go to our score.
And then right here for our, actually,
I think we need to do this, yes, for our score.
So make sure our score is selected.
Bind, Create Binding.
And this is going to create our binding.
But what are we actually going to be doing?
Well, what we're going to be doing
is creating this little bit of blueprint code.
What this code is going to do is
it's going to go out to our player pawn.
It's going to cast to our vehicle blueprint,
and then it's going to get the current score.
And then we're going to take that current score
and we're going to format this text
so that it will say score,
but the value that you see there
will be reflected from the getCurrentScore.
So this is really cool because this means
that we can have a text value
that signifies what this is and then have our number.
And we don't actually have to manage two different widgets
to get the same information.
So let's go ahead and pop over to the editor now.
And first things first,
we are going to get player pawn.
So there's our get player pawn.
And then from our player pawn,
we are going to cast to,
we want our advanced vehicle pawn
because that is the one that we're using
for this example.
We're going to then right click on this
and convert to a pure cast.
And once we have this in a pure cast,
we are going to look for as the vehicle advanced pawn,
our current, and there we go, getCurrentScore.
And I'm going to pull this over here.
So next, what we need to do
is we're going to pull off of this
and we're going to look for format
and we might need to disable context sensitive.
There we go, format text.
So oops, just going to undo this for a second
and go ahead and delete that.
So there we go.
All right, so with our format text,
what we need to do first
is we're going to put in score, semicolon,
and then we're going to put in two curly brackets
and then the word value.
And when we do this,
what we're going to get is right underneath that,
we're going to get a value.
So we're going to input our value
and then we're going to take our result here
and plug that right into our return value.
So again, what we're going to first do
is get our player pawn.
We are going to cast to our vehicle advanced pawn
because that's where we're doing all of our calculations.
We're going to get our current score.
And then using that value,
we are going to first put the word score semicolon
and then this value.
And that is what is actually going to be added
to our particular piece of code on the UI
or a piece of information on the UI.
I'm going to compile and save.
And what we're going to do next
is we're going to do the same thing,
but this time with our time.
So we're going to select our time.
We're going to do basically get game mode,
cast to our vehicle advanced game mode,
and then get our time remaining.
So let's go ahead and do that now.
So we are going to come back to our,
not our event graph, but our designer.
We're going to select time.
Then remember content, text, bind, create binding.
There we go.
And then what we want to do is get game mode.
So get game mode.
There we go, get game mode.
And then we are going to cast to,
oh, because it's called vehicle game mode,
vehicle advanced game mode.
There we go.
We're going to right click on this
and convert it to a pure cast
because we know that we are getting
a specific value from in there.
And what are we going to do?
Well, we're going to pull off of this
and we are going to get time
and I'm going to enable context sensitivity, get time.
There we go.
Get time remaining.
And what do we want to do with this?
Well, we want to format.
So we're going to look for format text.
There we go.
And what do we want to do?
Well, this is going to be our ME, so our time.
And let me just make sure that we get a,
and then we're going to do bracket and curly bracket,
and then value, like so.
And last but not least, plug this in and then compile.
And we make sure that we save our blueprint.